um I mean I got yeah i know i don't it's
like what would I do if I were Bill
Gates you know and I don't not that I
don't know if he does enough you know if
you really have it that for infinite
amount of money i think i would build
schools i think i would i think i think
that i think you know my educational
solution is just is a nice school and
every teacher should get 100 grand a
year minimum and i think you get a lot
of people who would teach you know i
think they're a lot of smart people who
are most comfortable in a school
environment who if they thought oh I can
make a good living doing this that's
what they would do that would be the
first thing I would do is it's fun
schools i'm sure i could you know i'd
give every teacher to in a grand salary
or you know see what happened after that
you know feeding people that's like dogs
so dog shelters you know I've also
thought like you know if you have that
kind of money you could sort of make you
could pay to make sort of picture
perfect pornographic sort of versions of
Disney cartoons would be funny you know
or like like a parody of like mad
magazines for the 1977 like a fake issue
and that would look exactly like the
real man magazine and you would whether
it and whatever and just print up a
thousand copies and then sort of salt
them around book stores around the
country and you just kind of blow
people's minds